what's up everybody it's your boy Travis
we back here 12 talks my bad my mic was
messed up just now first we got coach
Prime talking about how he doesn't break
up fights and practice and he keep
records of who
wins the team right now I mean you're
what man we've had a great week of
practice we had a couple fights which I
like is that a good thing that's a great
thing right yeah when you have a couple
fights that's that's a great thing and I
always want to know who won because I
keep records yeah I don't break them up
some some coaches break them up I don't
break them up cuz some guys fight hoping
for the breakup no we going to let you
go if you're going to commit commit
right commit we're all in so we did have
a couple fights this week and I love it
and they've been getting after it and uh
it's almost like a rededication you know
it's almost like a
refocus yeah that's basically
it yeah that's how it be man oh also
last week y'all did little
I told yall the Chargers got that good
defense I lost last Monday but yeah he
keep recording who win in fights so
players be doing that school man I mean
I practice some people get mad some
people want to
fight yeah so
be with the bills doy y the bill sold y
yesterday or
something Broncos one
have I got any fights no the
bill I don't know what y'all want me to
tell y
also we got next uh they found the
little people that not the little people
the kids that uh stole the
jewelry at the Rose
so they was on official visit I recruit
still jury you on the official visit
what are you still in jury for I don't
know but yeah you found still in jury
so they found the people hopefully the
people that got their stuff stolen can
get their stuff
back y'all get your stuff back I don't I
didn't get nothing stolen from me
so I got on
chains can't steal nothing that I don't
wear
sorry you play Xbox no I play PS4 I mean
PS5 PS4 is crazy PS4 you tripping no I
don't play PS4 I'm playing I play PS5
and PC Call of Duty yeah I play Call of
Duty fortnite 2K fall
guys play a lot of stuff here and there
all right next we got uh shador scoring
first
touchdown n it's not it is the first
time oh yeah it is the first touchdown
yeah us just let get in the end zone
once
again we came out to a hard start we
just got to finish we got play
everything together and finish the game
that was all on us nobody else fault
that was our
fault we got to finish the
game yeah this is me breaking up two
passes at once I mean playing
two two players at once yes sir BR the
ball
up I was beat but I seen this dude
comeing across so forgot my dude play
the other
[Music]
dude yeah
BR up the pass I should have picked
that I really should have been a pick
not a break up
next yeah I told y we should take more
deep shots and then we finally take deep
shots complete
them we could have did this the whole
game but
hey we we'll probably call more def shot
sooner or later cuz it's always over
that one was kind of on the throne but
we still completed it so it don't even
matter we need called more deep shots
but
hey I ain't the coach at the end of the
day yeah sometime my boy be out there
trying to avoid everybody he should have
just threw the ball though threw it away
got rid of the ball second and 20 I mean
30 and 20 there nothing else you can do
with
it touch
down yeah L touchdown the
lead you know how we get
man we we really be out there ding it up
we just
gota we got to finish man we GNA be
finishing great plays great call so we
don't be finishing we got to start
finishing yeah five
catches 74
yards two through for
262 two touchdowns really should have
been for more but it's all good what we
got
next yeah we was Bing the whole game you
got a great little catch on me in the
end zone
I should have picked
that I should have picked
that good look at nothing I can do about
that right there it's a great catch
great throw ball placement just
perfect call passing like that's just
not good defense but you know that's all
it
be
guess what it car right there offensive
passing the
Finish yeah man it's all good game up
short it's all be now it's time for
overreaction and not an overreaction
let's get right into
it get car it's crazy not overreaction
BR that junk is crazy bro like give me a
ticket bro cation bro like come on bro
I'm not going to be about no boot your
boot me for what to make an extra little
$100 it's not doing nothing
bro but yeah not of reaction getting the
boot on your car is
crazy sign stealing isn't cool
overreaction I mean bro you got to do
everything you do you got to do
everything you can to
win I'm pretty sure a lot of teams
probably took a lot of Team signs just
they they just got caught so reaction
it's like bro some the teams probably
done did that already doesn't even
matter at this
point they did go to exra 24
hours win on the road in this
environment when there were doubts sh
what does it mean to
you
want to thank the Lord want to thank
Coach Harbaugh [__] love you
man love this [__] out of you man this
for you with this University the
president our ad we got the best players
best university best alumni in the
country love you guys these [__] guys
right here these guys right here man
these guys did it these guys did it man
talk to him man love
you
yeah cry is loud man not overreaction
bro he cry
bro over
reaction Crown is a l but he just proud
it mean a lot to him
so it's the better the blue BL was it I
don't
know rushing the field after unranked
win so reaction yeah oh Duke vers North
Carolina
Duke was UNR yeah that's the Battle of
blue BL though yeah they like Rivals so
yeah that's not
overreaction yeah it's not overaction
hey they rival so I get why they Rush
the
field rest the field because they they
rival
so I'm pretty sure if UNC was unranked
and Duke beat him Duke fans with r the
field
too what
half time out
this not no reaction there definitely
Howa they got a freaking
dog
yeah they
IDE yeah they out of ideas
we got
[Music]
next I could do that too y'all but
that's tough that's
tough that's
tough shouldn't be able to do this in
cleat no a reaction you should be able
to you can do anything CL for but
moonwalk get moonwalk and
cl a touchdowns in the game is
ridiculous
yes that was
ridiculous not overreaction
buddy I mean overreaction that is
ridiculous bro eight touchdowns in the
game is crazy who do they play though oh
they play West Virginia yeah
[Music]
but the
r got him make the
catch R found himself in the wrong spot
just like on Longest
Yard we got that bro watch the throw oh
yeah I
seen I seen that nut
mag yeah d That's
crazy not overreaction I mean yeah not
over reaction you need to watch this sto
man got to stop
that what we got next two two for two
for 6 161 yards in the video game is
video game numbers yeah that
crazy how do you throw for that much I
mean somebody CAU 100 yard in a six yard
got or 80 and
yeah that's a lot of yards bro for two
for two two
touchdowns e over the touchdown it's
crazy yeah that's crazy
video game numers not over
reaction Washington drew it up no that's
not how they drew it up buddy he dropped
the ball way too early and I think 52 on
Utah smart move go get that
ball but still get a
safety this not how they Dr it up though
over
reaction
the I don't know what the hell he
talking about what's going
on over reaction
guessing I don't know what's going on
with
him all
right all right we switching it up this
week last week y'all messed around pick
the Jets over the Chargers and the
Chargers won so the mean I want because
I told y'all to pay attention but yeah
who we're going to start a
college uh a a PO and who do you think
will be the need to be the number one
college
team we need to be
the who need to be the number one
team in that college
[Music]
a Michigan Michigan is killing everybody
right
now who we got who we got who we got
Michigan number
one Georgia number
two migan number one Georgia number
two God damn these votes going
crazy we
got oh everybody participating now
that's what I like to see
oh Georgia number
one okay Michigan number
two Florida state is clearly in
third Ohio state is in
last no Ohio State fans in
here who y'all
got who we got who we
got come on now uh prob I think Georgia
should be number one Michigan two
Florida state three Ohio State
last that's what I see all right y'all P
this lock in what we got
final time for The Final
[Music]
Countdown
Georgia first Michigan Second Florida
State third Ohio State
last that's St people is locked in
Twin all right new fortnite came out two
weeks ago new Call of Duty came out last
week I'm going to rank my top five
celebrity celebrity athletes that are
the best Partners to have in those
games
I don't know I just be playing the game
with the
guys who should I play the game
with who should I play War Zone 2K with
well first first is quo because I be
playing the game with quo a lot man be
playing 2K in Call of Duty so one is
definitely
quo with
Bri number two Bri who else should I
play with
li who else
though be on that 2K going crazy oh Juju
Smith Shuster yeah remember I need to
play with Juju
Shuster I play fortnite with shador
sometimes he suck though y'all ain't
gonna lie
he's
Kar oh I know who play the game that I
would play with
carony
towns yeah I play with
c and Tar Hill they playing fortnite
some sometimes I play with Tar Hill yeah
that's what I play with oh I should have
used coach Prim coach Prim don't play
games you gota play somebody that play
games who not getting kills in fortnite
boy stop I'm like that
fortnite all right now it's time for a
blur let's get into it
Let's
Go
Blue head top head top to my enemies I
seen this out that was a nice
catch great
catch I don't know how he caught that
but he caught
it
blur oh I didn't see that Replay that
was a nice
catch oh yeah great catch one hand catch
definitely blur next what we got
next to
L blur I guess that was a blur thought I
was going to be on this head but that's
a nice good catch
too Lane to
lose hey great
catch all right y time for what's next
we'll play a video pause in and I gotta
guess what
happens we got here what we got here
what we got
here n he definitely not going run out
the back of the end zone crazy 95 yard
touchdown
what y'all
think ball goes off receiver Fort let's
do
see crazy 95 yard
touchdown nope right up the receiver I
knew I should have went with down could
be see two times in a
row
let's go what we got
next all right
buddy QB goes do the
Pit
Boss wait scooping
score B it can't be C again huh it's got
to be B right
B scooping
score yep gone he's gone
knew
it I already knew that I'm like
that gota be
be they can't do the LA they can't do
the same thing the last team did last
week all right y'all it's your boy
Travis 12 talks it's time to wrap this
thing up what we got to do this weekend
win very simple play Washington State at
Washington State gotta go in there win
we know it's gonna be cold we play them
on Friday
which is in two days we got to go in
there and
win that's basically all we got to do go
out there play our game put everything
together get this D try to get this bowl
game it's first week of playoffs for us
so we got to go in there win win or go
home see y'all next
Monday it's your boy Travis Hunter with
12 talks and we out appreciate y'all
love y'all see y'all next
Monday
[Music]
pap